There's four ways to buy anything and
I'll show you one unique way that's what
actually got me this building. And so
let me walk you through it. You've got
what I would consider past money. So
that would be savings. So that's
earnings that you had in the past and
that's money that you put away. The next
money is you have income money. So this
is the money that you make every single
month. You can spend this money rather
than touching your savings. This makes
sense. Then you've got debt money which
is basically future earnings. like this
is money I'm gonna take debt and I'm
gonna pay with future money, right? And
I'm gonna have to pay this debt off. And
then finally is the category that I like
to have, which is, and I'll call it new
money. Now, you're like, what does that
even mean? That's what I'll explain. So,
I've noticed amongst the friends that I
have that are the best with money, that
they're wealthiest with money, they
they're okay buying things that are bit
grandiose, right? Now, some of them buy
big houses. Some of them make buy big
cars and buy big yachts, big build big
buildings, whatever it is, right? And I
had a business owner who came here and
he was like, "Hey, I'm choosing between
two offices. I've got basically a
sensible office and I've got a much
bigger office that I'm really excited
about." He said, "Which one do you think
I should take?" And I said, "Which one
do you want?" And he said, "The big
one." And this guy was a very good
salesman. And I said, "Okay, here's the
deal. You can buy the big one. It was
two and a half times the size um or at
least two and a half times the price and
it was a little bit nicer, whatever." I
said, 'But the deal is you got to pay it
off in a
year. He was like, I can do that. And I
was like, right, then don't worry about
it. And so the thing is is that I would
say these are kind of almost like
different personality types in terms of
where people are taking the money from.
Now, the reason that I bring up this
building being a significant purchase is
it was less that the price was a
significant purchase and more so that I
didn't need this building at the time. I
just wanted to have a place to have a
home gym that would be more than like
it' be like a commercial gym. And I
wanted to have place for meetups and
things like that. And I could come up
with a rational explanation that between
all the portfolio companies, we were
spending about $4 million a year in
event spaces. And I was like, well, if I
had a big enough space for all of them
to do their their internal meetings,
their quarterlys, fly out their staff
and their team, and have a venue, then I
could probably save that and it would
pay for the building. But I remember
Leila was like, "Hey, you know, we
should maybe maybe we should just get
like a 5,000 foot building." So, this
building's about 36,000 ft², much
bigger. And I remember hearing this and
I was like, I mean, that's appropriately
sized for where we're at now, but it's
not the size building that I would want
it to be for where I want to go. And so,
I remember telling her, I said, I
promise if we buy this building, I will
make sure that it makes us more money
than it has cost us. And I would say
that a behavior that has served me
extraordinarily well is looking at new
money. Meaning, if I buy this building,
can I find something that will pay off
the building? Now, of course, I had the
expenses on on the portfolio side. We
could have just saved the $4 million a
year that we spend in venues and all
that stuff. Sure. But I was like, is
I'll bet you there's something that we
can do with our existing resources, and
this is the key part, is that it's
sawdust money. It's money using your
existing resources that you're currently
underutilizing to generate new money for
a specific project. And so my favorite
way of doing this is like if hey if
Daniel wants to buy a boat or wants to
buy a car, I love the idea of him being
like so I'm just going to work one extra
day per week over the next year and then
I'm going to buy it. The richest people
I know, that is the behavior that they
typically use. I want this thing and so
I'm going to go make the money to buy
the thing. I'm not going to use my
existing income. I'm not going to use my
existing resources. I'm not going to use
my savings to buy it. I'm not going to
go into debt unless I know that I'm
going to pay it off within a year and I
have no prepayment penalty and I have a
clear plan of how I'm going to do it.
They have a clear plan of how they're
going to make the money in a very
defined time period. And it's from doing
above and beyond. It's looking at all
the stuff you got. And the reason that I
like this is I was talking to a good
friend of mine, Chiron Cervatza. He's a
president of Real uh actually just
became a board member, excuse me. And he
said, "Oh," he said, "you just want to
write yourself a swimming pool." And I
was like, "What does that mean?" He so
he said, "So Paul McCartney, uh, the
Beatles used to say he wanted a swimming
pool." And, uh, everyone's like, "Well,
what do you like, how are you going to
pay for it?" Now, obviously, he has the
money for a swimming pool, but he didn't
want to use his savings. He didn't want
to use his income and his royalties. He
didn't want to go into debt for it. And
so, what'd he do? He was like, "I'm just
going to go write a song." And so he
writes a song and he writes himself a
swimming pool from the money that he
collects from selling the song, right?
And so I think about this a lot because
I think it's it's a different way of
thinking about money. It's like I'm
going to I want this thing and so I
don't want to limit my that thing. If
anything, I want to use that thing to
motivate me to find other resources. So
what I'm being is resourceful rather
than draining resources I have. I'm
finding new resources by utilizing
existing assets um that are currently
under my control. And so this is
fundamentally like people were like,
"Well, you know, you could Airbnb one of
the rooms out." And like, "Okay, that's
one of the things I'm going to do, but I
also have some time." So I was like,
"Maybe I'll drive Uber." There was one
of my favorite customers ever at my gym.
She was a mom of four, single mom. She
didn't have the money for the gym
membership. And she was like, "Well, I
could drive I could drive Uber one day a
week and that I would be able to afford
it." And I was like, "Great, then do
that." And so that's what she did. And
she was one of my longest standing
members, lost 100 pounds. And it's like
there's a there's a shift that happens
when you decide to do it that And I
think there's something to be said about
creating a vacuum, about creating space.
I've heard the saying like make yourself
poor, right? Of the idea of like how do
I how do I create this deprivation? How
do I create this this threshold that all
of a sudden increases my my my demand
for money, right? Because everybody has
a demand for money. Like you have a
certain lifestyle that you have grown
accustomed to. And so that's your
minimum threshold. That's your minimum
requirement for for living. The real
wealth comes from being able to continue
to jack this up while keeping this low,
of course. But in those instances when
you do want to buy the sweet ride,
because I'm not like people think of me
in as an aesthetic, and I am to a large
degree,
but if I want to buy a sick ass home
gym, which I do have, I would rather
that money come from new stuff. either
you can do extra stuff to get the thing
or I think the 2011 version of this is
how do I use the thing to make even more
money. And so part of the reason we spun
up the advisory services was actually
like me fulfilling a promise to Leila of
like okay we'll find a way to use the
building uh to generate income to cover
the building because I do want to have
this sick home gym which will be a
complete and other waste of space. Um
besides the fact that I think it's dope
and why have money if you can't spend it
and you can't take it with you anyways.
And so this may seem like a a wild
departure from some of the content that
I make, but this is obviously targeted
at someone who probably has a little bit
more is a little bit further along. All
right, if you are broke, don't do that.
If you're broke, just focus on the new
money stuff, right? But if you have
some, I think that you stay ahead of
your spending by not increasing your
lifestyle relative to your income, but
by increasing the new money relative to
the new purchase, which typically are
defined. And so it doesn't have to be
forever. So if you're like, well, I
don't want to work overtime all the
time. Fine. then you can just work
overtime for a year, work overtime for
six months, work overtime for a month so
that you can afford the thing. And I
think it's always when you think about
it like that is I have to take I have to
add this on top. I don't I don't touch
my flows, right? I don't touch my income
flow and I don't want to create a
liability with the debt and savings is
like that's my nut, right? I don't want
to I don't want to, you know, use up my
my nest egg, right? So, I got to go make
it. And it this has just been this
behavior that I've observed from the
people that I know that are the
wealthiest and the people who enjoy
their money the most. And I think that's
the thing is like it's one thing to have
money because I I know plenty of people
who who obviously have money, but some
of them I don't think they enjoy their
money and it's because they're always
it's it's like they're like afraid and
there's some of this whole idea of like
you have to be abundant and all that
stuff. I know tons of people who are
super scarcity mindset and have a lot of
money because they just don't like
spending it. And so like there's
something to be said for that. But
that's if you make money the goal. And
if you do make money the goal, then by
all means, don't spend it because then
money is the goal. So fine. But if money
isn't your goal, then the people that
I've seen that are the happiest that I
think spend money well. They use money
like a tool is they use an expense or
use something that they know they're
going to consume. They know it's not a
good investment and they say, "Fine, I
know it's not a good investment, so I'm
not going to use my income to buy it.
I'm going to use something that I
already have that I'm underutilizing,
which might be just your time. You might
take on a new client project. You might
take on some one-on-one services that
you wouldn't normally take on, right?
Those types of things can be defined
period because you're like, well, it's
not going to increase the enterprise
value of the business. It's not going to
be some sellable asset, but I do want
this thing and I don't want to touch how
my existing infrastructure functions.
It's just one behavior. And I think many
of you like if you're like me, like I
don't like I don't like spending money.
And I've tried to learn my way out of
it, which is I don't like spending money
that's like my main money. It's like my
core money. It's the money comes in from
businesses, distributions. That's my
main thing. But if I want to buy
something crazy, then I've just got to
be willing to do something crazy for it.
And the weirdest thing happens is that I
get almost more excited about making
that money than the money that I make
every single day because I know that
that money is going to towards this
specific thing. So I'm like, I'm I'm
building a home gym right now. I'm
buying equipment right now. Like that's
my as I'm doing this, I'm almost like
more joyful about doing the work because
I know exactly what it's going towards.
And so just a little behavior that I
picked up over the years, something that
I've observed in other people that I've
used myself that has been wildly
valuable. And if you have that, you
know, if you've got two machines that
you could buy for your business, you
know, and one's a little bit sweeter
than the other, and you can't really
justify the expense, then just take the
Delta, be like, I'm going to go make
that myself because I think it's sicker.
And I have never been disappointed about
doing that. Not once have I done that
and been like, this was a mistake. And
the thing is is that I've bought plenty
of things that I that I I thought were
expensive, right? But I can minimize my
regret by saying I'm not using money
that I otherwise would want to use
somewhere else. And so that's my little
money behavior that has served me very
well and I hope it serves you well. And
if you like this one little framework, I
have 28 frameworks that I teach in 22
minutes on how to reprogram how to think
about money. Enjoy.